[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros en 5
minutos cuando nos acompaña el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor gracias por acompañarnos europa
vive sin freno la segunda ola de la
pandemia de kobe 19 incluso varios
países superan el pico de marzo y abril
que factores han llevado al continente a
esta situación doctor
en europa lo que atendimos fueron dos
fenómenos el primero que cuando la
persona las personas sintieron que había
pasado la famoso primer pico pensaron
que eso no volvió a pasar y eso es algo
que en las otras pandemias hemos visto
que hay siempre nos regula y lo segundo
es que coincidió con las épocas de
verano en donde además de eso en el afán
de la reactivación económica se abrieron
bares se permiten aglomeraciones se
acumularon las de las playas y como si
no hubiera pasado nada y como ésta no es
una enfermedad que afecte rápidamente
sino se demora a todos 34 semanas
después del tiempo paulatinamente sería
el incremento de los casos y hoy puede
estar una situación bastante crítica
doctor le pregunta ahora entonces qué
papel juega la disciplina de la
población en medio de estas nuevas
medidas y la salud mental de las
personas que claman por salir
hay que tener en cuenta que las medidas
de confinamiento son medidas que son
extremas es cuando el comportamiento
individual y social no ha podido
controlar cuando se toma la decisión por
parte de un gobierno de hacer un cierre
total es porque nosotros no fuimos
capaces de autorregular entiendo que
todas las personas tenemos necesidad de
salir de compartir pero en este momento
hay que hacerlo con moderación y con
autorregulación porque nosotros tenemos
que celebrar la vida y no tenemos que
celebrar situaciones trágicas y hoy
tenemos que tener el compromiso de que
es nuestro nuestro comportamiento el que
define el comportamiento del virus el
virus no va a definir el comportamiento
nosotros somos nosotros en los que
decidirlo y eso como lo hacemos con la
autorregulación y con sinceridad hacia
nosotros minutos doctor qué pasó en el
verano para que hoy esté pasando esto y
qué podría pasar con la llegada del
invierno
en la llegada del invierno va a haber
más personas que estén dentro de sus
hogares va a haber menos todavía de
ventilación y asociado a eso el
incremento de las infecciones
respiratorias que son asociadas al clima
frío que se exacerban es decir que se
pueden acercar dos o tres problemas la
circulación viral o el rebrote es decir
que hay muchos mayor personas infectadas
y muchas mayores personas asintomáticas
sumadas a que las personas van a estar
recogidas en sus hogares entonces va a
haber mayor probabilidad de transmisión
por eso esta época de invierno va a ser
una época en europa de mucho cuidado
disciplina de autorregulación sobre todo
detección busquen hacer que tiene el
diagnóstico para arreglarse
tempranamente ahora los sistemas de
vigilancia epidemiológica y también los
rastreos de contactos están siendo
insuficientes
es mucho es mucho más lo que se necesita
nosotros no podemos seguir siendo
demandantes es decir esperar a que la
gente se enferme o que tenga un contacto
para hacer las pruebas tenemos que ir a
buscar a dónde se están haciendo ese
saneamiento se hacen muchísimas más
pruebas en los países de la región
lamentablemente tenemos el mayor número
de casos pero todavía no hemos comparado
con el mayor número de pruebas que
necesitamos solamente sabiendo quién
está enfermo se aísla quien posee el
virus se alivia y es la única forma que
selectivamente nosotros podemos
controlar el producto mientras no haya
pruebas suficientes y se necesitan por
lo menos duplicar o triplicar el número
de pruebas no podrá ser no media más
efectivo doctor hablamos entonces lo que
ocurre en europa en este momento luego
de quitar el confinamiento general
espero lo mismo américa latina
en américa latina viene dos desafíos en
los países que tienen estaciones por la
estación invernal en los países
tropicales que no tienen estaciones
viene la época de lluvia sumado al
aumento de los brotes y sumado a las
festividades navideñas en donde nosotros
somos especialmente proclives hay el
comportamiento social al alcohol a las
reuniones familiares a perder un poco la
el comportamiento entonces es necesario
que todos nos controlemos porque puede
suceder una tormenta perfecta en estos
meses doctor gracias por la información
buen día hasta aquí cinco minutos con
hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]